Damen und Herren darf Sie recht herzlich
zur heutigen Pressekonferenz mit der
Frau Verteidigungsminister Claudia
Tanner im Gesundheitsminister Johannes
Rau und dem Rektor der Medizinischen
Universität Wien ein markus Müller
-verteidigungsministerium ihre Eröffnung
ja vielen Dank Herr Hauptmann sehr
geehrter Herr Bundesminister sehr
geehrter Herr Rektor vor allem am
heutigen Tag aber sehr geehrte Herrn
Militär Medizin Studenten sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren der Presse das ist eine
Premiere heute die wir feiern nicht nur
weil wir das erste Mal in unserem neu
gestalteten
Presseraum uns einfinden sondern weil
wir eine so gute Kooperation gefunden
haben mit dem Bildungsministerium mit
dem Gesundheitsministerium vor allem
aber Herr Rektor mit ihnen mit der
Medizinischen Universität Wien wo wir in
dieser Gemeinsamkeit glaube ich ein sehr
hervorragendes Projekt auf die Beine
stellen konnten das was wir gesehen
haben sehr geehrte Damen und Herren das
auch wir als österreichisches Bundesheer
nicht verschont geblieben sind vom
generellen Ärzte Mangel unter die
vollständige Sanitätsversorgung unserer
Soldatinnen und Soldaten das ist
mancherorts und da haben ja auch Sie von
den Medien immer wieder auch berichtet
darüber besonders im Auslandseinsatz
wirklich eine echte Herausforderung
geworden wir müssen im Bereich des
universitätswesens des Bundesheeres
vieles voranbringen das eine hat mit den
Menschen zu tun das andere hat aber auch
mit den Investitionen zu tun wir haben
erste Schritte gesetzt und einiges schon
geschafft wir werden in den kommenden
Jahren mehr als 30 Millionen Euro
investieren in die Infrastrukturen wir
werden weitere 10 Millionen Euro
investieren in neue feldambulanzen das
heißt eine Art bewegliche Krankenhäuser
verlegbare sanitätseinrichtungen und wir
wollen auch
autarke sanitätsversorgungen in den
Kasernen schaffen ein Fokus oder
vielleicht einer wohl der wichtigsten
liegt auf der Erhöhung der Kapazitäten
der personellen Kapazitäten im
medizinischen Bereich ja und da ist es
unser gemeinsamer gelungen dass wir ein
neues Modell in Österreich zumindest
neues Modell zur ärztegewinnung
geschaffen haben das heißt aber dem
Wintersemester in Wahrheit sehr geehrte
Herren der eigentlich seit der gestern
sind sie im Weg eines sondervertrages
für 20 Jahre beim österreichischen
Bundesheer beschäftigt sie werden dann
die Möglichkeit haben in dieser
Dienstzeit an der Medizinischen
Universität soziale auch abgesichert zu
studieren und dann die anschließende
Ausbildung zum arzt für Allgemeinmedizin
oder Facharzt zu absolt Viren je nach
Fachrichtung die sich die Herren
versuchen ist dann eine mindest
Dienstleistung von 8 bis 11 Jahren beim
Bundesheer zu erbringen als ausgebildete
Militär Ärzte werden sie dann in einer
der Krankenanstalten des Bundesheeres
oder als Truppenarzt in der
sanitätseinrichtung einer Kaserne tätig
sein wir haben einen sehr großen
Leistungsbereich abzudecken der bei der
allgemeinen Medizin beginnt über die
anästhesieaugenheilkunde und so weiter
bis zur
Unfallchirurgie besteht es ist auch
vorgesehen dass die Militärärzte
zumindest im Zeitraum ihrer mindester
dienstverwendung alle drei Jahre für
sechs Monate einen Auslandseinsatz
absolvieren ja nach dem Ende dann der
geplanten
gesamtverpflichtungsdauer erhalten Sie
zusätzlich eine Ausbildungsvergütung
können sich dann entscheiden ob sie das
Bundesheer verlassen was wir natürlich
nicht wollen sondern wir hoffen dass Sie
eine weiterführende Wirklichkeit dann
bei uns beim Bundesheer anstreben die
Voraussetzungen die sie schon erfüllt
haben und die hinkünftig als
militärmedizin Studentin Student zu
erfüllen sind das ist zum einen einmal
dass die Bewerber eine militärische
kadereignung über eine militärische
kadereignung verfügen müssen sie müssen
aber auch den regulären medizinischen
aufnahmetester bestehen und dort zu den
besten 25 Prozent der im jeweiligen Jahr
angetretenen Bewerber liegen und das
eine ist natürlich auch klar es muss ein
Interesse auch da sein an
abwechslungsreichen Tätigkeiten im
Inland und im Ausland nachdem sie jetzt
diesen Studienplatz erlangt haben werden
Sie bei Militärspital sanitätszentrum
Ost aufgenommen die dienstliche
hauptverpflichtung das ist das Studium
das ist das Medizinstudium in den
lehrveranstaltungsfreien Zeiten absol
unsere Studentinnen und Studenten dann
zum einen die im Studienplan geforderten
medizinischen Praktika zum anderen aber
durchaus auch
Zusatzausbildungen für den militärischen
Alltag sowie für den Bereich der
Menschenführung ich glaube was auch
wichtig ist dass wir auch vorgesehen
haben eine Jobrotation innerhalb von
ganz Österreich durch alle unsere
medizinischen Dienststellen
sanitätszentren und so weiter so dass
sie auch sehr frühzeitig dann integriert
werden in das militärische
Gesundheitswesen auf dass wir sehr stolz
sein können sie sehen hier hinten die
Leiterin die Frau Brigitte mit ihren
Mitarbeitern auch ich glaube das ist ein
sehr interessanter Ausbildungsplatz den
Sie hier erhalten was auch wichtig ist
das ist die Kooperation mit den zivilen
Krankenanstalten ich kann Ihnen hier
sagen dass es reges Interesse auch schon
gibt und an dieser Stelle auch noch
einmal ein ganz großes Dankeschön an der
Bundesminister für deine Unterstützung
und auch die Bitte für kumpfkünftige
Unterstützungen wenn es um Kooperationen
dann geht's ein Vorteil den unsere
militärmedizinstudentin Studenten auch
noch haben ist dass sie Sport machen
werden so wie alle anderen Soldatinnen
und Soldaten auch das ist nicht nur
erlaubt sondern das ist sogar erwünscht
das ist ein Projekt das eine Premiere
feiert und das was wir gesehen haben ist
dass es auf reges Interesse gestoßen ist
wir hatten über hunderte Interessenten
aus 21 Interessenten haben dann
mit einem vierwöchigen
Vorbereitungskurs wurde dann eben die
Ausbildungsprüfung von diesen sechs
Bewerbern auch geschafft den
schnapswachtmeister ein Korporal und
vier Gefreite sind dann gemeinsame
Rektor mit rund knapp 6000 andere
Bewerber waren es um diese 68
Studienplätze auch angetreten und wir
sind sehr stolz darauf dass sie das auch
geschafft haben sie damit die ersten
sind die diese neue gesetzliche
Möglichkeit auch genutzt haben
abschließend noch einmal ein ganz großes
Dankeschön Herr Rektor an sie für die so
gute Zusammenarbeit im Sinne der
Gesundheit aller Österreicherinnen und
Österreicher und auch dir Herr
Bundesminister für die gute
Zusammenarbeit wir dürfen niemals
vergessen dass nur gesunde Soldatinnen
und Soldaten einsatzfähig sind und dann
auch verteidigen und helfen können ich
danke Ihnen
ich würde nun den Gesundheitsminister
sehr gerne geschätzte Kollegin Thanner
Herr Rektor geschätzte
jugendmedizinerinnen kann man schon fast
sagen
ich möchte die Gelegenheit nutzen zu
Beginn liebe Kollegin Tanner mich ganz
herzlich bei dir
stellvertretend aber insgesamt beim
österreichischen Bundesheer zu bedanken
für die Unterstützung die Arbeit in den
letzten zweieinhalb Jahren wir hätten
die Pandemie ohne die Unterstützung des
Bundesheers in ganz vielen Bereichen
nicht in dieser Art und Weise bewältigen
können es gab
vielfältige rasche bestens organisierte
Unterstützung zum Beispiel beim
beim Aufbau von Test und impfstraßen im
ganzen Land flächendeckend mit bestens
ausgebildeten Personal es gibt die
Unterstützung in Gecko unserer
Beratungseinrichtung
und ich mag das einfach an dieser Stelle
nachher Tätigkeit sagen herzlichen Dank
für die Unterstützung wir zählen
weiterhin darauf ich kann
selbstverständlich auch anbieten die
Unterstützung von unserer Seite in all
diesen Fragen wir sind sehr froh als
Bundesregierung bestrebt im
österreichischen Gesundheitswesen die
Voraussetzungen zu schaffen dass wir
auch weiterhin
ein gutes für alle leistbares und
sicheres Versorgungssystem haben wir
wollen das Gesundheitssystem zukunftsfit
machen wir setzen Initiativen wie die
Einrichtung jetzt eine Erfahrung hast
wahrheitstil für Allgemeinmedizin wir
wollen die Primärversorgung ausbauen
alles Punkte um der Bevölkerung einen
guten Zugang zu ermöglichen dieses
Projekt hier
sind besondere Erwähnung weil wir damit
ein gewisser Weise Neuland betreten und
aber eines tun
einen doppelten Nutzen stiften es gibt
einen Nutzen für das österreichische
Bundesheer in der Sicherstellung einer
guten qualitativen medizinischen
Versorgung durch eigenes Personal und es
gibt von ihrer Seite aus und das möchte
ich ausdrücklich erwähnen schon die
Bereitschaft sich auf einen großen
Schritt einzulassen sie verpflichten
sich für sehr lange Zeit
im Gegenzug zu dieser zu diesen
Ausbildungsplätzen das ist schon ein
mutiger Schritt und da ist ihnen auch zu
danken aber sie verpflichten sich damit
nicht nur sie stellen damit auch sicher
dass sie dem österreichischen
Gesundheitssystem erhalten bleiben und
ich hoffe natürlich irgendwann wenn sie
sich dann doch entscheiden aus dem
Bodensee auszuscheiden was ich jetzt
nicht anbrechen anregen möchte gibt es
immer noch die Möglichkeit im
österreichischen Gesundheitssystem tätig
zu sein wir würden Sie herzlich
willkommen heißen wir brauchen jedes
Personal aber ernsthaft gesprochen der
Elektro wird es bestätigen
wir haben insgesamt einen sehr sehr
hohen Bedarf an ausgebildeten
medizininnen und Medizinern und insofern
herzlichen Dank an sie dass sie diesen
Schritt wagen sie leisten einen ganz
wichtigen Beitrag hier beim
österreichischen Bundesheer
selbstverständlich auch für die
Gesundheit insgesamt in Österreich danke
schön
ja schönen guten Morgen herzlichen Dank
für die Einladung liebe Frau
Bundesministerin lieber Herr
Bundesminister ich wäre noch ganz kurz
ein paar Worte aus Sicht der
Medizinischen Universität Wien sagen
wie Sie wissen ist die Medizinische
Universität Wien eine sehr große
Institution mit einer Reihe von auch
öffentlichen Aufgaben
kobit-krise wurde angesprochen ich
glaube es ist vielen Österreichern auch
bekannt geworden im Rahmen dieser Krise
was in diesem Land geleistet wird vom
Bundesheer aber auch von unserer
Universität
wir haben also neben der
Versorgungsleistung die sich
hauptsächlich durch das größte Spital
Österreichs das Allgemeine Krankenhaus
hier in Wien manifestiert mit einer
Versorgungsleistung von etwa einem
Drittel der urbanen
entzugsmetropole Wien vor allem zwei
andere Aufgaben die Ausbildung junger
Medizinerinnen und Mediziner das beginnt
beim Studium geht aber dann weiter in
verschiedene
ausbildungs-track der Facharztausbildung
auch hier sind wir eine der oder die
größte Ausbildungsstätte für Fachärzte
in Österreich und dann natürlich auch
die Forschung ich glaube das Thema das
uns alle beschäftigt ist Verantwortung
wir haben wir sind zwar eine autonome
Universität aber wir teilen öffentliche
Verantwortung gemeinsam mit den Ressorts
mit denen wir im Austausch sind
insbesondere Gesundheitsministerium das
Verteidigungsministerium und das
Ministerium für Wissenschaft und
Forschung und ich bin sehr glücklich
dass der Gesetzgeber hier auch
unsere Aufgabe konkretisiert hat und es
zu einer Novelle oder einer Möglichkeit
im Paragraph 71c des
Universitätsgesetzes gekommen ist
Studienplätze nach einem gewissen Schema
von dem sie gehört haben für öffentliche
Interesse zu reservieren insofern ist
das heute hier eine eine echte Novität
was auch vielleicht auffällig ist dass
wir von Dichterinnen auch sehr herzlich
gratulieren dass wir hier sechs junge
Medizinstudenten vor uns haben also es
sind sechs Männer das ist für uns
relativ untypisch weil die Medizin sehr
weiblich geworden ist also mehr als die
Hälfte aller an Studienanfängerinnen bei
uns in sind junge Damen und das ist ein
ungewöhnliches Bild heute aber ich darf
Ihnen auch sehr herzlich dazu
gratulieren danke vielmals
Verständnisfragen habe ich das richtig
verstanden 21 haben geschafft und diese
sechs sind jetzt für dieses Jahr gesamt
die diese Ausbildung machen werden und
jedes Jahr sind sechs oder Dienstag die
Quote vielleicht
kurz die Ausbildungsplätze
Medizinstudium auch nach den zivilen
Aufnahmeprüfung betreiben dürfen aber
das sind das
unterstütze und was ist mit Frauen
das Bundesheer es gibt eben
immer stellvertretend ist für den Erfolg
aber das
sieht man ja da haben sie vollkommen
recht das ist ein gewisser auch
Wermutstropfen wenn daher Rektor
anspricht die Medizin ist weiblich dann
ist es leider nach wie vor bei uns beim
Bundesheer so dass wir einen einen
soldatinnenanteil von 4,5 Prozent haben
und hier sehr viele Lüfter nach oben ist
was jetzt die Medizinstudenten anbelangt
das war so dass es im Jahr 2022
135 Interessenten gegeben hat davon
waren 18 weibliche und 117 männliche
dabei es sind dann am 8 Juli 2022 21
Bewerber angetreten da war eine Frau mit
dabei eben unter diesen gesamten 6000
Bewerbern für die Studienplätze und das
sind jetzt die Sechser die sozusagen die
Anforderungen erfüllt haben die Prüfung
geschafft haben und damit mit zum
Medizinstudium zugelassen worden sind
die Formulierung so wie sie jetzt das
ist ist dass es bis zu zehn Personen
sind im Wege eines sondervertrages die
eben dann für 20 Jahre eben beim
österreichischen Bundesheer
Beschäftigter sein werden
also zur Frage der Quote also wie gesagt
es gibt ein
mindestleistungserfordernis das genannt
wurde so 25 Prozent oder die 25
perzentile
wobei ich sagen darf ohne ohne hier
Geheimnisse zu verraten dass einige der
jungen Männer auch so einen Studienplatz
bekommen hätten also wir haben 680
Studienplätze heuer Angeboten für
Humanmedizin und einige hätten das auch
ohne die Quote geschafft nicht alle
und die Quote wie gesagt ist im
Paragraph 71c definiert
einige davon werden auch während auch
sozusagen ganz normal
nein nein das nicht
Tee na eben nicht nein Sie müssen sie
haben alle den mit der Tee machen müssen
eben mit einer mindesterfordernis im
Abschluss das liegt bei 25% der besten
geknüpft eben an die Bereitschaft in den
Dienst des österreichischen Bundesheers
zu treten oder für eine gewisse Zeit
lang zu verbleiben aber wie gesagt
einige hätten auch völlig
natürlich sozusagen einen Studienplatz
bekommen
grundsätzlich ja
wird dann geknüpft auch an
Verpflichtungen das ist ja sozusagen das
System so wie es jetzt aufgestellt ist
ein gewisses Privileg zu genießen
nämlich in den Genuss dieser Plätze zu
kommen ich habe im Gegenzug zu
verpflichten das ist auch vorstellbar
beispielsweise für den Öffentlichen
Gesundheitsdienst oder für andere
Bereiche wo sich dann die Auszubildenden
oder die Studenten stellen verpflichten
im Anschluss eine Ausbildung eben der
öffentlichen Hand im weitestens
hinzufügen
ja das ist ein gewisse Herausforderung
und wir sind natürlich bestrebt durch
diese Regelung oder das Ausschöpfen
dieser Regelungen dann noch sicher zu
stellen dass wir die Menschen die wir
ausgebildet haben im System haben
verlängere Zeit
vielleicht neue ergänzend der große
Vorteil ist ja auch dass auch eine
Bezahlung nicht mehr erfolgt durch das
österreichische Bundesheer das heißt
eine eine Absicherung dann da ist eben
vor meiner Bezahlung die die Hälfte der
Bezahlung einer militärperson auch auf
Zeit ist sollte jemand der frühzeitiger
außer dem Studium im Ausscheiden ist
selbstverständlich dann dieser Betrag
auch zurückzuzahlen
da wird er vielleicht auch noch etwas
ergänzen was was mir wichtig ist
also meine Generation
ist in der Generation der sogenannten
Ärzte Schwämme aufgewachsen damals gab
es in Österreich 20.000 in die
Ärzteliste eingetragene Medizinern
derzeit gibt es über 45.000 in die
Ärzteliste in Österreich eingetragene
Mediziner und es wird von einer Ärzt von
einem Ärztemangel geredet also der Ärzte
Mangel ist kein quantitatives sondern
wie wir heute auch sehen eher ein
qualitatives Problem wir haben also
punktuell Versorgung Schwierigkeiten das
hat also viele Gründe die man im Detail
analysieren muss wahrscheinlich
aber wir verlieren leider relativ viele
junge Absolventen ins Ausland also
Schweizer deutsche Kollegen sind immer
ganz glücklich sagen wir immer bitte
schickt uns mehr Absolventen weil die
brauchen wir das heißt die
Herausforderung ist es nicht noch mehr
Absolventen zu generieren ich sage immer
das ist wie wenn man sagen einen Kübel
mit Lauch hat und und oben mehr Wasser
rein schüttet wir müssen alles dazu tun
um die Attraktivität des ärztlichen
Berufes in Österreich zu stützen und zu
steigern und ich glaube genau das wird
hier beim österreichischen Bundesheer
gemacht also hier eine
klarplanbare Zukunft einfach geschaffen
wird um den sicher punktuell bestehenden
mangeln Militärärzten zu beheben aber
man kann sicher nicht sagen dass wir so
ein quantitativ in Österreich zu wenig
Leute ausbilden mein Lieblingsbeispiel
ist immer die Charité die Charité ist
die größte deutsche
Ausbildungsstätte ist etwa dreimal so
groß wie die Medizinischen Universität
Wien also Budget Personal etc aber die
Uni Wien bildet mehr oder oder
kreiert mehr Absolventen als die Charité
also nur dass man das ein bisschen in
den richtigen Kontext drückt
Soldaten
wie sieht denn tatsächlich dann die
Bezahlung
wir sind bei neu 1000 Euro pro Monat auf
den Cent genau kann ich das dann auch
noch nachreichen was vielleicht wichtig
ist das ist der mehr als das Stipendium
dass es dass es gibt wenn man diese
selbst erhaltungsstipendium erhält das
was ohne Zweifel zukommt auf die
Medizinstudenten neben der neben der
Absicherung das ist sehr viel an
abwechslungsreicher Tätigkeit ich habe
es vorhin schon anklingen lassen
insbesondere das was mit den
Auslandseinsätzen zu tun hat da haben
wir sehr vieles sehr vieles am Bedarf
und ich denke da ist dann auch noch
einmal von der Bezahlung mit
berücksichtigen wenn man
selbstverständlich dann in diese
Einsätze auch geht und im Ausland dabei
ist dass es dann nach den gesetzlichen
Bestimmungen dazu auch noch Vergütungen
nehmen gibt
ganz über das ganze Jahr um jeden Monat
bzw
ein Sanitäter der
als Benutzer dann wird das bezahlt was
jeder andere der in den Auslandseinsatz
auch geht selbstverständlich an
zusätzlichen Geld auch bekommt das gilt
auch für unsere Studenten
gibt es noch zusätzliche Fragen zur
heutigen Pressekonferenz
sehr gut dann würde ich vorschlagen dass
man kurz umbauen sozusagen
und ich würde es versuchen kurz auf der
linken Seite
beginnen mit Herrn kooperei Guardian
Schober und ich darf er das erste
Dekrete zur Verwendung bringen dass ja
gleich laut und für alle ist gemäß
Paragraph 7a Absatz 1
Vertragsbediensteten Gesetz 1948 in der
geltenden Fassung wird Ihnen für die
Dauer der Verwendung als
militärmedizinstudent bzw
militärassistenzarzt mit Wirksamkeit vom
ersten Oktober 2022 der Dienstgrad
Fähnrich tu erkannt herzlichen Oper
danke sehr
so wir dürfen
fortsetzen
mit
ferngehalten Maximilian Sandner den wir
entsprechend der gesetzlichen
Bestimmungen des Vertragsbediensteten
Gesetze für den
Dienstgrad Fähnrich zu erkennen dürfen
verbunden mit den allerbesten
Glückwünschen
wir dürfen nach vorne bitten den Herrn
gefeigten Stefan Konstantin jonesco den
ich gemäß den entsprechenden
Bestimmungen des Vertrags Bediensteten
Gesetzes den Dienstgrad Fähnrich zu
erkennen da verbunden mit den
allerbesten Glückwünschen alles Gute
wir setzen fort mit Herrn
stabswachtmeister Julian Bann den wir
gemäß
zu erkennen dürfen verbunden mit meinen
mit unseren Glückwünsche
danke
sehr gefreuter Amir merimi
gemäß
Vertragsbediensteten Gesetzen 1948 in
der geltenden Fassung wird Ihnen für die
Dauer der Verwendung als
militärmedizinstudent bzw Arzt
mitwirksamkeit vom ersten Oktober 2022
Fähnrich zu erkannt alles alles Gute
die Premiere
für die Dauer der Verwendung als
militärmedizin Student bzw Arzt mit
Wirksamkeit vom ersten Oktober der
Dienstgrad zehndrich zu erkannt alles
alles Gute
gemeinsames Foto suchen mit allen bitte
danke sehr